let's say I'm surprised to hear that
companies fail to report
maybe they fail to report in a timely
manner maybe they failed to report
anything in far too many cases target
comes to mind we find out about the fact
that they've been hacked by people who
who find out about the fact that they're
you know they're that all this customer
information is available in the black
market right is it possible that a hack
on the scale of a Sony might be going
unreported well it's interesting that
some of these companies are finding out
from the media that they've been hacked
or finding out from the government that
they've been hacked the worst case for a
company is to find out you've been
hacked when your system stops working
which we saw in some of these cases so
in many cases when they discover they're
hacked they're not reporting for various
reasons we want to break down those
barriers we want to improve the
communication between the government in
the private sector in this area it's
absolutely critical that we have the
information necessary to address the
threat and we're asking companies to
share their information with us but one
thing I want to ask you about as well as
we've reported on the JP Morgan breach
which your office is obviously
investigating that one of the things the
bank really wanted was a national
security exemption letter and how common
is that for companies to ask for
exemptions from disclosing what is that
well under certain state laws that
require disclosure there are exemptions
to the requirement and one didn't want
to report that they have no I'm gonna
talk about the JP Morgan case in
particular but in general state laws
often require that companies report
certain types of breaches with certain
exemptions one of the exemptions is if
there is a law enforcement need to keep
the breach quiet keep it close hold so
we can continue to investigate in most
cases that's not necessary and it's very
rare that we issue what is a hold
harmless letter or ask the Department of
Justice to issue a hold harmless letter
to a company so that they don't have to
disclose it so without having to refer
to a particular investigation which is
ongoing I'll just say in general terms
it is a rare thing I think a rare thing
to be asked for and a rare thing to
grant as well Oh Thor oh yeah what's the
what's the threshold for granting one of
those like well we'd have to show an
investigative need so for example if the
adversary is still on a network
and we want to monitor the at the
adversary on the network we'd like to
keep that information from the public so
the adversary obviously doesn't
we're not telegraphing to the adversary
what we're doing and what we're watching
so in those types of cases we'd ask that
they not make the public disclosure
under state law if these companies seem
to be understaffed or unprepared for
these hacks does your office have the
right amount of funding and staffing to
get what you need done well
funding and staffing is always a
challenge it's not just the challenge
for the private sector it's a big
challenge for the FBI as well as we
build our capacity we're finding that
the threat is growing as fast or faster
than our capacity to address it so even
I mean it just seems that this is such a
quick fast moving target it is difficult
to keep up with the technology is
changing the landscape is changing the
threat activity is changing we're seeing
more and more sophisticated actors enter
this landscape so the expertise is rare
and it is difficult to hire train and
retain we are competing with the private
sector we're competing with other
government agencies we think we have a
lot to offer in terms of professional
satisfaction service to the country we
distinguish ourselves in that sense in
terms of the FBI hiring process but we
still have a hard time finding the right
people and keeping the right people what
does it mean practically if you can't
keep up with the growing threat well
will it need to enforce the laws but it
doesn't mean that quarks are getting
away it does mean that I think the
reality is if we are not paying more
attention to this problem we will see
the threat increase in our ability to
keep up with it not keeping pace it's
it's it's undeniable that the number of
breaches is going up that the
sophistication level is going up and
despite our best efforts we are
constantly surprised by new and
innovative ways to affect these
important networks well I've heard I've
heard breach investigations described
between federal law enforcement and
companies as they can be a hostage
situation in many cases that we reported
that there were some delays in JPMorgan
turning over data related to its breach
to the FBI and we had one person tell us
that you know these situations can often
devolve into what amounts you
a hostage situation over data how common
is that so that's that's a good point
and the question really should be how
does the private sector work with the
government when they have a breach and
the FBI and the Secret Service have done
a great job over the last few years in
changing our tactics so that we have the
least negative impact on a company when
we show up so for example if there is
sensitive information on a network that
the company is concerned about
disclosing we're very sensitive to those
needs and we'll work around that we can
compartmentalize the information we need
and take only what's necessary for the
investigation so in that sense we're
saying we are listening very carefully
to what the private sector requires in
order to break down the barriers to
cooperation sure I also want to ask you
about attribution as well I mean to go
back to the JP Morgan example just
because it's its freshest you know you
have a lot of ex-military folks very
senior folks inside private sector
corporations now who have a lot of
experience in attributing attacks on
government networks and we reported that
the JP Morgan senior cyber security
leadership believed this was a Russian
state-sponsored attack FBI determined it
wasn't how often do you see that I mean
are you seeing a lot more of that now
with the worthies senior military folks
inside companies attributing information
without access to the resources that the
FBI has that's not a trend that I'm
noticing and certainly not something
that we would be tracking there's a lot
of cyber talent out there that
Department defense is generating a lot
of cyber talent and if they have a
certain viewpoint it may shade but we
don't see that and I am seeing that in
any of the cases that I work léo in the
case of JP Morgan hackers got alarmingly
far into the companies networks what we
haven't seen thus far is an attack on
financial markets themselves how close
what does the FBI know how close have
hackers whether they be criminals right
trying to make a profit or nation-states
trying to disrupt this country's economy
come to penetrating and messing with the
integrity of America's financial market
well we have seen some some activity
that is troubling such as why well
general clapper the DNI the other day
for the first time disclosed that Iran
was behind the attack on the Sands Hotel
in Las Vegas so we
see yet in other nations they not just
trying to create an annoyance and get
attention but actually conducting an
attack that was destructive in nature so
I think that we would be well served to
prepare for I won't say a catastrophic
attack but an attack that has an impact
that may shake some of the confidence
levels neccessity on the stock market
bond market currency markets those are
very very well protected systems and it
would be extremely hard but we thought
JP Morgan was well protected - these
were two hundred fifty million dollars a
year III agree that we're always
surprised but what we have to keep in
mind is that most of these in payment
systems and trading systems are closed
systems they're not open to the Internet
the biggest threat is when you're open
to the internet or when you're open to a
third-party vendor that's open to the
Internet so if you have a closed network
that you can monitor and detect
intrusions or keep an eye on better
because it's not connected by email or
otherwise it's easier to protect the
system like that and I think that's what
most of our infrastructure is composed
of but we have to actually be very
vigilant about it it's a concern for us
what's been the most shocking hack for
you
well obviously the Sony hack has really
changed the way many of us think about
it that was that had three very very
scary elements to it first of all there
was the theft of intellectual property
which we can understand from a financial
point of view some hackers would engage
in but also the extortion that came
after and the destructive nature of the
attack really changed the minds and this
has been publicly attributed to North
Korea so when you have a sovereign state
conducting an attack against the private
network with that much impact it really
did raise some concern the
administration came out publicly the FBI
came out publicly and we are very very
concerned about that type of activity
that's before you the is the amount of
security technology that is inside
private sector companies does that help
or hurt your investigations there's a
lot of data being generated by a lot of
different vendors and we talked a lot of
companies that say we don't know how to
make heads or tails of a lot of this
information right part of these by
everything part of the challenge in
these investigations is a complexity of
the network's many of our many of the
folks that we visit after an attack
don't know what's connected to their
network they
network topology they don't know who's
on their network some cyber security
technology claims to address that but no
protection is perfect it requires
continuous monitoring actually that the
the the notion that you can protect your
perimeter is falling by the wayside the
the the best organizations out there are
monitoring they are detecting what's on
their network before it becomes a major
impact but for you the bottom line is
you want companies you want General
Counsel's to feel comfortable picking up
the phone and calling you you're not
gonna come in with a bunch of yellow
tape and sort of cordon off for crimes
that's right when we respond it's not
with Ray jackets and evidence tape we
are working with companies we want them
to call us we want them to have a plan
and we want to be part of that plan